[Music]
[Music]
oh what a lad in my word do i have one
of the
biggest lads in the game on the podcast
for you today not only is he an absolute
lad but he's also one of the greatest
players to ever play the game he
literally is one of the greats he's done
it all he's won the super rugby
rugby championships bledisload cups the
rugby world cup and he's twice been
named the best player on the planet
he is the biggest name in world rugby it
is of course the one and only
bowdoin barrett welcome bears thanks
jabba
i missed out on a top leg recently so
that actually hurts me to
bring all those up but still a bit of
time to get that
i had it penciled in too i thought you
guys were home
oh now that pretty good side yeah
yeah how did you find the top leg over
there
um [ __ ] it was an eye opener um
not just the rugby but the whole
covered scenario living scenario
um i guess the rules and restrictions
like
we didn't play one game all year where
we
were allowed to have a beer after the
game just little things like that
yeah um the big reason why we sort of
play is you know you train hard with the
boys
throughout the whole week and you enjoy
those moments after the sheds cracking a
ten or two
but um yeah no it's just black and white
um even for the not uh for the
foreign players like we live in a we
lived in a
an apartment block together like the
real strip rules around us seeing each
other and so on so
from a social side of uh things it was a
challenging six months but um
the lads were great lads the suntory
boys
um very good club to be part of and
yeah the rugby was it was surprisingly
good footy like the gap between the top
and the bottom was
pretty big but um when you get in the
top top six or eight teams you're
playing some decent footy but you made
it look incredibly easy you were scoring
for fun but it was actually it was
actually tough even for you
mate like we've got some good players in
our team and yeah against the
um weaker opponents so to speak
uh yeah there were moments here where it
looked like we're playing school boys
but
um yeah like i said the teams at the top
they're very good teams and
um i think it's going to get better up
there
the university footy is very strong and
there's a lot of keem
young players out there coming through
so you know people
it's a different game to what it was
four years ago up here or five years ago
people think that you come over to japan
for a holiday but it's everything about
that
train like buddy tarzan
long training so is that even at suntory
too i thought they might have
sort of had a bit more professional
approach it was
professional but the load management was
an eye-opener like we don't speed on a
monday after league weights
that morning and we play on saturday
it's like honestly i
and to the credit they get on with it
there's not many injuries and
yeah it really opened my eyes up but
it's not something i'll be
continuing back in new zealand
well that's one thing with the japanese
players though they'll never question
reasons of why or even game plan and
stuff they'll just
always just say yes and just do it hey
but i guess that's what the foreign
players do a little bit differently you
would have been questioning all sorts
like i struggled at the start i was at
the was at the back of the room biting
my tongue in a lot of meetings but
um you know you talk to the foreign
players you offer suggestions
if you've got a good case and it's
rational they are very open to
to change um yeah but if you go on there
you know and you don't sell it well
they're probably just going to nod say
yeah and then move on and
nothing will actually happen so you've
got to be
yeah quite rational and have good
meaning behind any sort of change you
want to make but
it was fun with you i i thought they
might have because it was you they would
have just
listened to whatever you said but no you
had to still sell to
sell the dream as well or they listened
but
whether there was change or not
[Laughter]
so outside of rugby outside of training
and playing you were just
pretty much um you just had to be in
your
apartment did you you couldn't really go
out well we could go out
um we had to wear a mask every time we
you know went out um you know
han and the girls would often meet for
coffee and lunch and so on because they
just
needed to for sanity uh but we weren't
allowed to go out
for a coffee lunch dinner with
any teammates you were allowed to host a
team mate
up to eight o'clock because after eight
o'clock you start making bad decisions
so it's time to go home so there are
heaps of these rules it was um
oh undoubtedly we we pushed the
boundaries
at times because we needed to to you
know
to remain sane and um
to celebrate a few wins along the way as
well well there's plenty of those for
sure
how do you think the top japanese teams
would go against
super and super rag there yeah i
genuinely
think uh the top so like
um panason tori kubota
toyota even tj's team would
um would go pretty well
yeah i don't i think the top four
wouldn't look out of place in the
trans tasman true competition
if you were at santori would you win
trans tasman
we actually guys like samuel kirivi and
sean mcmahon and
um harry hawkins and that like we were
talking about it quite a bit
yeah um thinking gosh it'd be cool to
play and even
um nagi our halfback and ryota at 12
just thinking gosh it'd be cool to play
super rugby
um yeah you know the appetite for footy
and playing against
kiwi and australian teams is so strong
and
they're just hoping for the opportunity
or yeah they're very open for something
like this
um because they're bloody good players
yeah is that the next step you think uh
for super rugby to
introduce japanese sides like that oh
i'd love for that to happen
um yeah there's a lot that i have
learned from playing in
in japan and i think
uh yeah they would offer some
significant value to the competition
with the way they play
uh it's it's fast
generally fast ruck speed um
continuity's right up there the ball and
play time is right up there
honestly it's some good footy good footy
to watch
um yeah for that reason
and would all black players be allowed
to play over in japan
gosh this is um who knows
these are the i mean i would love for
japan teams to play on the super rugby
but then obviously it comes down to the
contractual rules of new zealand rugby
how that
you know at the moment there's that's
all negotiation
uh brody sam white lock and myself
tj had the opportunity to play uh
so there is a little grey area there
it's not black and white yet
um yeah australian rugby have the ghetto
rule i think if you play
over 60 or 80 tests for the wallabies
you can come back and play
play for them um if you're playing your
franchise or club rugby offshore so
yeah i don't know that may come into
play at some stage but at the moment
i think our game's in a good enough
state here where there's plenty of
talent coming through and we don't
need to do that i hope you're on the
players association board you've got
some good stuff in that here
that's one thing japan rugby needs
actually
yeah you should take over japanese one
i wouldn't know where to start no jesus
some stories that come out about
contracts and all sorts over there
not ideal but anyway what a career
you've had
so much stuff to try and get through in
a
podcast but we'll try and touch on as
much as we can
but like all good stories it's got to
start somewhere so
a lot of people want to know where you
how your story started because
obviously two other brothers have become
all blacks you guys were obviously doing
something right
what was that um
gosh we had some real good games of
backyard footy
and world-class with
with some the crowley um brothers
crowley family
just down the road that's uh logan he's
now playing for
the stags and he's back playing in
taranaki and daniel um so we had some
good numbers
um yeah occasionally jen and my
the oldest younger sister played to make
up numbers to even it out but
yeah we watched dad play for coastal and
taranaki and the hurricanes and
um they were so supportive and
encouraged
to see us play and yeah it was just a
passion from a
young age we all loved kicking the ball
around getting out there
um sliding in the mud we used to have a
floodlight out on our
on our lawn um where we could go out and
in the wintertime kick kick and you know
muck around play force back right
through to dinner time at 6 30 so
yeah it was just a genuine passion
yeah who was the gun at a young age like
in that backyard who'd you want on your
side
kane was always like obviously kane and
i had to
go one each but then after that
geordi was always a good distributor and
he had a good eye for space and and
timing and that but he was always the
runt he was always the youngest
so it's whether you wanted a bit of bulk
with blake and scott
or whether you go for the skill with
geordie so it was always tough and then
you throw daniel and logan crowley into
it it's um
it was never it was never the same it
was always good fun
so what's the age difference between you
all uh
well kane is uh 31 on 30
scott's 27.
oh yeah blake 20
506. jordy i think's 24.
jenna's maybe 21 zara
18 ella 16. there's a decent age gap for
geordie oh yeah yeah but he was brave
he used to just fly and low at the knees
like and just
hold on for dear life it's probably why
he's so courageous these days and
represents
everything yeah well now that he's got
massive
he still plays like that little fella
that needs to be he does needs to be
brave
short fused too we used to wind him up
well he's still got that
and blake how how did blake go because
he's obviously the one that
a lot of people won't know but he by all
accounts he was one of the most talented
oh he was he was real good um
gutsy uh just your typical
grinding loose forward um
with good skills good game awareness and
that um
unfortunately just struggled with a bit
of size when he got to
you know his late teens and yeah in that
position you need to be
quite big to have some impact and
dominance so that's probably where he
um unfortunately didn't kick on to
higher honours but um
in terms of skill and work rate like
he's up there with you know the best
true oh get him a contract good
cricketer too
is he yeah you all were too weren't you
except probably kane yeah except kane
uh kane was into his fishing more so in
the summer would get out the
lawnmower get out the big roller and the
bcg would look pretty good
would have um the cousins would come
over once again josh down the road josh
barrett's a good cricketer
um yeah we'd be out there for hours in
the summertime
get the old ball out and insulation tape
make it swing
all the tricks who was the gun cricketer
jordy
geordi was known for his worm burners so
he used to steam in with
fire in his belly and just bold decent
line of length
and he'd just like he'd have tears in
his eyes because he'd try that hard
and occasionally he'd just clean us up
because the ball would go under the bat
and it was known for his worm burners it
was probably the only way he got us out
so like scott was good he has a steady
uh
out swinging bowler decent better same
with blake
but yeah geordi was the funny one and
were you always a freakish talent like
in terms of rugby like
were you always naturally gifted
um i i don't
think so like from a physical point of
view i wasn't
freakish or gifted or anything like that
um i was quite a runt actually
and you know i was always
uh i think when i went to france douglas
in year nine
um i might have been in my late sixties
no mid sixties oh yeah uh
early sixties so i was really small
played half back
and oh yeah yeah eventually
grew a bit taller and um
turned into a 10 15. um but no i
but i sort of i guess the difference was
i made up for it with my passing and
kicking off both hands and
feet and um i was quite fit as well so
i had to work hard and were you fast
no i i wasn't it wasn't until um
probably my first summer out of school
uh when clarky laidlaw asked me to play
sevens
yeah i was getting into starting to do a
bit of leg weights
and started to realize a bit of speed
and
i think against men because i wasn't a
big bloke i realized i needed to
be evasive and and be find some pace and
i did that summer um we played down in
queenstown
played for the nike sevens and um
even then i surprised myself made a
couple of line breaks and i thought oh
gosh
where did this come from but i think it
was genuinely
like probably a good six week period of
hard training
um and that sevens sevens training got
me prepped for that tournament
that's awesome six weeks and you just
got flying
it was quite a daunting transition
because you you obviously you missed out
on new zealand schools too didn't you
yeah so it was around that time um i was
finishing up
i was tossing up whether i'd go over to
melbourne
and play some aussie rules and go to
university there
or go down to dunedin and become a
scarfy
yeah and thankfully clarkey gave me this
opportunity which
went down to queenstown touched picked
me on the new zealand squad and
um i didn't want to be a scarfy and be
in the new zealand seven squad because
that wouldn't last too long i'd imagine
so i stayed stayed in the nike and um
got a job and yet continued training
with the uh
academy actually with taranaki rugby so
how close were you to going to afl like
how far
how far through that did you get so we
had a brother brother peter
smythe um an australian
man was a teacher at france douglas and
he was passionate about
aussie rules often he'd have me down
there on the field at franz douglas
practicing my afl punt
which is a great way to practice how to
punt properly and um
it's always hoping for one of the boys
from france douglas to go over and play
aussie rules yeah and he almost had me
but
um yeah it was probably the
sevens opportunity that um
i took if that didn't go well then yeah
it was a genuine chance
true man what a different career that
would have been
yeah would it would have been a fun
experience i love the game it's a great
um quite a simple game um
but yeah it was i gave it a go it's more
just the those handles
um getting the ball away and it's a bit
different at passing a rugby ball like
you've got to sort of punch it out so
all those sorts of things would have
taken a bit of
time or transition but in terms of
running
uh fitness punting catching like i
thought it would have suited
me yeah so tj would obviously look to
going
to league would you ever look to do a
late switch over to afr
oh no not now
not now it's um i still
practice with afl ball i've carried i
carry one with me wherever i go
it's good fun but um no it's it's too
big a shift to make now
um no fair enough it is it's not quite
as similar as
league to union is it it's it's a little
bit different
that is and i mean
this 30 year old engine it'll be quite a
step up playing i don't know how many
k's they run a game
it's 15 plus some of them
yeah but let's be honest your running is
not an issue you could run for years
yes now it'll be a big call to go over
there and play
afl but um i still watch it it's great
yeah great game to watch
so go back to your new zealand seven so
titch called you in
um after carving up for taranaki down in
queenstown
what was it like going into that
environment gosh it was um thankfully
ben sonis and crack baker took me under
their wing
made it made a lot easier um
i was so intimidated by you know dj
forbes and
um czar lawrence guys like that
timmy nicholson also took me under his
wing so i was thankful for that but yeah
i was scared of touch like [ __ ] scared
of touch
but lucky you were you would have
dominated the fitness testing and all
that
now the boys i mean it's quite an even
playing field when you get to that level
um we used to do a test called the
phosphate where you run
10 40 meters every every minute or
something and
this might be 30 seconds yeah and it
basically because they know your uh 40
meter sprint time one off so titch is
watching it the whole time and he
watches to see if you decline or how big
the decline is and yeah crutch used to
clean that up
um but
yeah some of the or definitely the
harder sessions were those
were those um mount maunganui camps
where tits
absolutely bossed the trainer said look
you're done and then he finished off the
session
just went old school with it yeah
and then you're obviously impressed
you're impressed enough to make
um a few tournaments
yeah made two actually at the end of the
season um
i had to be quite very patient so i was
playing a little bit of club rugby for
coastal
and um yeah still
actually um trying to do that
hypertrophy
program because i was still a runt uh at
with the academy boys at
at the union in taranaki um and at that
time coops offered me a contract with
taranaki so
i was playing a bit of coastal club so
that sort of set up the year nicely
in may i made um i got selected to play
the
twickenham and uh murrayfield
tournaments
so got a little tour under my belt and
then
uh yeah into a mitre 10 cup season or
back then it was
itm i think and you made an instant
impact for taranaki i remember the big
long mop um skinny brain
you mustn't have been much more than
just still boyweight because you were
still very scared yeah burst onto the
scene weren't you
yeah i was in my 70s um
like maybe 78 kilos
yeah so that's that's a little bit
lighter than damien mckenzie
but uh obviously i'm a bit taller than
daimler so i was a rake
but did you feel comfortable because you
were at 10 2 weren't you so you're
obviously um running the cutter for a
pretty
experienced taranaki squad yeah
um leo and coops managed me really well
i was off the bench for most the games
willie reapi started most of them and um
i learned quite a bit from him in terms
of uh how to manage a team or run a team
yeah it was so daunting guys like craig
clark and
pig eaton yeah
literally guys who was at school the
year before watching going to the game
yara stadium watching them play and now
i was playing with them
it was pretty pretty scary scooter
waldroom
you know some great players and you're a
big part of
a shield success was it i'm not sure if
it was that year or the year after but
it was a year after year that was taught
me through that one
yeah so good um
yeah we went down to invercargill
actually the stags had the shield for a
decent stunt a number of weeks and um
uh yeah we managed to win
i think there was four points in it
two points in it there wasn't much in it
just one of those cold
wet invercargill nights and um we
managed to win the shield
still one of the best moments rugby
moments in my in my career
but we had to get back on the plane and
uh we had a four day turnaround
four or five day turnaround um so we had
one defense against the hawke's bay
so then have it for the summer which we
achieved and that's when we got to
really celebrate
oh that would have been a good one and
oh i coulda it
uh at our flat you can imagine it
jason eden jared hawata oh
crap baker
krato yeah
an absolute test so then um in 2011 you
made the hurricanes wider squad and i
think you managed to pick up a few games
towards the back end of that season
yes i was um chipping away trying to
put some size on davey gray had me doing
10 gym sessions a week i absolutely
hated it
but eventually got a chance um
i think croods got injured in
melbourne and i got called over because
the they went from melbourne to
south africa which i came off the bench
and that next game against the cheetahs
we won 47
50. i think drushie or kalsi scored on
full time and it was oh
yeah but that yeah so that was uh my
first cap
had a good night that next uh that night
and then we went to
um cape town for some reason and i was
rooming with andrew hawe
and i just i honestly didn't see him all
week
apart from that training um so i was
made aware that
uh hammer cut him as as
as captain and um
oriben hoary uh went to the pub
most nights and that was the way he
prepared for
the sharks that next uh weekend and he
played an absolute screamer
still playing yeah he honestly
had the best game of the season and i
was sitting there on the bench like how
was this guy running
because i i could only assume what
they're getting up to but um
yeah that's to his critter he fronted up
that's just the old school
uh man he is the way the way he was and
i think james uh sorry jason eden was
his wing man
oh true yeah so then 2012 was when you
got your first full contract
yep there was um my first full year
and i was happy that i went about it the
way i did because i really did need that
wider training group year to uh develop
physically
but it but as well um i don't want to be
thrown in the deep
end as a young first five um
straight out of sevens not understanding
how to
run a game um because it does
take a lot of time i think being patient
there was crucial
so yeah i see a lot of young players
these days and
a good example is jacob nick nipkins um
at the blues like i'm happy that the
blues aren't rushing him
this year he's still a young very young
kid same school
very similar path to me but i just know
that he'll be a good player in the
future because
he's got a good head on his shoulders he
has been patient and
we know how talented he is he carved up
out of 10 last year and
yeah he's won one to watch so did you
feel comfortable when you got your first
start at the canes
i wouldn't say i felt like comfortable
but i was um
confident in my ability and ready to go
um based on the what i knew at the time
and the preparation that i had
i was more did i feel physically up to
it and able to
handle the force and power of these
big south african um players you know
even big aussies and new zealanders and
the answer was
yeah um i felt a lot better than i did
the year before
and you still had your speed from that
six weeks training
that six-week camp whatever it was
well you're gonna be able to start
selling um bodhi's six-week speed plans
for millions go and see davey gray he'll
sort you out
and then obviously he had a huge career
massive
influence on that hurricane side over
the last i can't remember how many years
it's been probably
seven or so years but now you've had a
huge influence on that squad
any highlights from your hurricane's
career obviously two finals
um were pretty special but anything that
stand out for you
um the 2016
final um
yeah to to lose the previous year
at the cape town and then come back and
one of the following year was so
satisfying um
to play a hundred was was pretty special
uh
to run out with big bama he was playing
his hundredth super game
same day and beat the crusaders uh was
pretty cool
but i guess when i look back on the time
of the canes it's more the
friendships and the i guess those
fun moments throughout the journey like
the days off
playing golf uh the trips to south
africa
um you know the chats and the changing
room
all those i think that's
prob those are probably the fondest
things um you know i won't remember
too many games um
but yeah i guess that's smelling the
roses and enjoying the moments along the
way is probably the most important thing
and i guess as
i look to finish up my own career in the
next hopefully 10 years
i just remind myself each day that um
you know just enjoy each day because
it's gone bloody quick
yeah it does eh well that's that's
powerful stuff mid podcast i like that
smell the roses
10 years maybe
what do you reckon i'm including coastal
senior thirds
how is your body feeling good though you
feel like you've got
plenty of years left yeah i went to
japan after
um last year's international season
um pretty like
not broken but my achilles was giving me
some
big troubles like i
i hadn't been able to work on speed for
um you know a good year and
you know i was literally limited to
60 minutes training time um one time a
day
for all of that international season so
it was quite frustrating um not to be
able to work on
extra things but also to start training
a little bit later
so that i'd be able to finish with with
the team so
went over to japan and we fixed it
and it's feeling really good and i've
been able to work on
um heaps of other things so i came back
to new zealand uh feeling really fresh
and after a season of
very fast footy up there um
yeah hopefully i'll be in good stead for
this upcoming
whatever is around the corner all right
how good is that and you obviously were
surviving the three hour training
sessions over there so no
time limits no time restrictions
they didn't go too long it was more the
intensity like
the amount of body on body just like
absolutely killing each other on a
tuesday
um yeah they they just i think it's the
samurai style in them
like they just are so brave and
courageous
and milton milton loves it too he's our
head coach
yeah he just he's been up in georgia for
a
number of years and i think he he gets
off on that
bone on bone the georgians do too
so then obviously you're all black
career uh 2012 you made your debut there
as well so that all happened pretty
quick
yeah it did um
it was played in hamilton actually
against the irish um
yeah went from rooming with richie and
dan and
to my first four weeks i was
throwing in the deep end there um
gosh it seems like a long time ago uh
but yeah
i was just a a young boy
uh i was like a sponge you know just
soaking it taking it all
in dc and croods were there um
i was learning so much from them just
waiting for my opportunity and
played little roles off the bench every
now and then coming on at 15 or 10.
um do all the banks on debut always room
with dc because it seems to be a common
trend the ford seem to
their first rumor used to be richie and
all the beck's first rumor used to be
dc i think it's generally the
new guys are roomed with the experience
guys
oh yeah so um if you're on a
three-week um say the upcoming
july series uh if there's a bolter or a
new guy they'll typically be
with the older guys yeah just uh
for whatever reason shandy makes the
call you're obviously the big dog now so
you get all the new guys dreaming with
you
no they'll be with nugget aaron smith
any other moments that stand out for
your all black career obviously
um the 2015 world cup was one of the
greats and there was a moment in that
game in that final
surely still gives me goosebumps
thinking about it yeah actually there's
a moment
um when ben smith got
yellow card and i thought oh gosh what's
going to happen here it's going to
affect me one way or another whether i
come on or whether
that's delayed or yeah so that was quite
nerve-wracking
um it's always new
coming off the bench um just
there's so many different variables you
don't know if you're going to come on in
the
20th minute i have for dc before um
when bismarck duplicity cleaned them up
and at eden park
so you've just got to be ready yeah
bendy got yellow card i came on a bit
later than probably
planned a lot for what i've hoped but
yeah obviously that last try is pretty
nice
yeah oh fresh legs the six week speed
program
in full full noise
did you always know you're gonna get
there
uh now that last
nudge it didn't i was hoping it would
have set up for me
before that but i had to somehow at
reasonably high pace and made contact
with my knee or shin
so i was so happy with how it came out
after that because
yeah they can go anywhere oh mate what a
try what a moment
but you you've scored tries like that so
often throughout your career these sort
of freakish tries which
look like um look like a bit of a fluke
but mate you've just got a knack of
scoring them consistently so you've got
a bit of a gift there
oh that that's very nice of you to say
um
it's honestly a lot of it's instinctive
you don't have time to think too much
you just
get on with it and do it but um
oh look there's got to be a degree of
learning those little skills when you're
mucking around
exploring uh playing in the backyard
doing
stupid trick shots or whatever with your
mates like there's a degree of
training for those moments yeah
and your speed obviously gets you is it
your speed because your speed
um like when you're tested for speed
you're not hugely rapid are you but on
the field like there's no one who will
ever catch you
oh no there is but
this just never happens yet no no it's
more that
uh from the early days like
i've always been fit and i guess if you
can be reasonably fast
and fit i think you just stay faster for
longer and
can outlast
out and out speedsters yeah because i
don't know
i'm not rapid i don't test fast it's
just
yeah when i get boots on when i'm on the
turf i feel probably the fastest i can
possibly feel other than probably on an
athletics track and spikes
yeah mate well your rugby speed is
definitely the quickest out there so
i'm glad you answered it like that
because that's what i said i think it's
your
ability to keep your speed you don't
lose speed no matter
how far through the game you are like
could be the 80th minute and you're
still
the same speed as you are when you've
first kicked off
goes back to that phosphate test that
tit us
do you know those 10 40 meters every 30
seconds or whatever
it's so relevant if you're back and
you're playing 80 minutes
um to be able to dig deep and have that
in your tank at the end of the game but
i mean look i'm 30 now hopefully i can
keep that up you've got the engine as
well haven't you because your bronco is
one of the quickest broncos ever
recorded
um you broke all sorts of records with
that last year and you've probably
beaten it since
no i haven't gone near it
it's i had a lot down to sort of prepare
for that
i mean yeah i worked
very hard on my physicality side of
things because there's nothing else to
do
but yeah i've always mum's been very
encouraging when it comes to the my
fitness like
she'd always encouraged me to run home
from school
when i was at primary school and it was
a 4k
uh run and that would prepare me for
cross country which
um i'd usually do pretty well at yeah
and it would set me up
you know for rugby and and whatever
other sport i decided to play so i've
got a
i guess the hard work was done at a
young young age and
although i may have been naturally
gifted you've i still had to work
work hard and you still do yeah it's
important
um you know there's
oh i don't like being complacent or i
don't like that
slipping in um at times because
there's always someone knocking on your
door um
you know there are people now knocking
on the door and it's always going to be
there so
i guess just got to keep looking myself
in the mirror asking if i'm
giving it as much as i can and
if i am then that's all the satisfaction
that i need powerful well you talked
about people knocking on the door so
2000 after that will cut when carter
left was this your sort of opportunity
to
try and get this um all black starting
10 jersey
yeah it was an opportunity um
i mean even with dcd i still saw it as
an opportunity
um i guess with completely different
players
um it just came down to
what steve and fozzie saw um
and yeah initially in that 16th season
they picked
croods and unfortunately he got injured
in wellington i think or in the second
test and
um yeah i managed to take an opportunity
and sort of run with it for a while
and never let go yeah it's um
i look back on it and it's been it's
been
every year has been so different um yeah
you know you throw in a lion series in
in the middle of it um
and then a world cup uh either side and
playing around with 10 experimenting
with 15 and so on
um yeah it's been a bit of a journey
and in 2016 this is your first year
you've sort of cemented the
all black ten jersey you become the
official best player on the planet
how was that that must have been pretty
surreal
yeah it was i guess i was so um
i was so caught up in the process and
the week to week of
preparing playing that
i was quite shook when i when i was
announced and um
almost embarrassed because i know how
much of a game this
i know how reliant i am on my teammates
around me and a
good ford pack and things like that um
that i was kind of surprised and
embarrassed to receive that award but
i guess that's just who i am um i didn't
expect it or anything like that but um
yeah it was nice to be rewarded for a
probably a breakout season yeah but then
you backed it up the following year and
you won it again
only only dan carter and richard mccall
had won it twice before and
you joined that less so mate how was
that one the second time round
um it was
once again i was reluctant because i
knew that i'd still had so much to offer
and i knew that it wasn't a perfect
season and
uh i knew how
good i can be because i hadn't reached
my potential
and you know i received that award so
yeah
i received it with reluctance and um
yeah it wasn't it wasn't too satisfying
to be honest well that's interesting did
you did you ever feel like you're the
best player in the world or do you ever
feel get that feeling like i am the best
that's so subjective and um
i just try and be the best i can be
because
i know i can judge that
um whereas this award is there's a panel
there's a committee or whatever that
selects it but um
yeah i pride myself on
i judge myself on myself because that's
my that's my mark i know
if i've achieved what i can or if
there's still plenty left in the tank
and so on
so yeah speaking to tj he obviously said
that
he's got a mindset where he feels like
he's
the best player on the field every time
he goes out on that
rugby field do you feel like that or you
your mindset's a little bit different
i'd imagine
um yeah i think i can relate to what tj
is saying
um in terms of
yeah you want to be that guy where
people are like wow look at him
but um
so much goes on in the game
[Music]
when you look back on the game when you
go through clips
i'll judge myself on look at that time
was i the best i could have been um
did i miss an opportunity here and i'll
get annoyed at
the smallest things that people probably
don't even judge or see or
or understand so it's one thing to look
at oh he scored three tries he had an
awesome game but it's all those finer
details where
i think individuals judge themselves on
um
and that's typically how i would reflect
on my games
speaking of scoring lots of tries
there's one game in particular
wii u oh you've done something before
that game
four tries against australia everything
just worked that game it was just one of
those moments where it must have been
like
wow what is happening here yeah exactly
for that game it was one of those
games with you know some the ball just
fined you
near the trial line in some games and
and you're the lucky one to fall over
and it all came together that day
for me from a try scoring point of view
but once again i look at that game there
are so many missed opportunities and
things that i was annoyed about um
but people think look he had an
absolutely outstanding game but
i'm sitting there like well his four
tries was nice but
you know that's what you read in the
newspaper but um you look at the tape
and
i'm there on monday kicking myself
well i look at my fantasy team and see
that you're my captain and
oh happy days
i can please the biggest fantasy score
in history you got that day
oh geez line breaks tries trices kicking
everything he did it all
but then the 2019 world cup in japan
talk me through this one yeah it was
it was a great um 10 weeks gosh is a
long time we're in japan
uh for a tournament um yeah
you know we're we're really enjoying
the footy um
i guess trying to take it one week at a
time one game at a time and earning the
right to plan a quarter final
and yeah there's a typhoon in the mix
where we
we missed out on a game against italy um
so that was
that was quite interesting um yeah we
lost
we lost our grandfather uh that was
very um sudden and
so sad just before the quarter final the
irish test so
there's quite a few disruptions and um
yeah got to the quarterfinal and we we
had the game of the tournament
against ireland we had previous history
where
there was a lot on it emotionally for us
and we gave yeah we
we emptied our tanks for them or on them
so i guess when you look at a semi-final
we
we didn't achieve that same
intensity which we needed to
and on the flip side england
brought that and they would probably say
themselves they didn't
bring it the following week so it's so
hard to back it up um
week in week out at that level
and the intensity it requires so
it was so unfortunate they played very
good footy
um yeah it was it was quite unfortunate
not to go
to do a three-peat and win three in a
row
yeah we wanted to most of us wanted to
leave straight after that game
we're like you know why should we hang
around and play playoff
you know for three and four but it was
actually really good that we stayed
we had no choice to be fair um but
emotionally you're like look i just want
to get out of there you just want to run
um you've had a massive low you've
missed out on the opportunity to make
the finals
and we saw it as an opportunity to see
rito and
um a few great players off to make it a
week about them and um
yeah we we put it on for them against
wales
we finished third um
which didn't meet our goals
but at least we finished on a high note
and we showed up and
got ourselves proud on the following
week must be surreal playing with
obviously two other brothers in the all
blacks
at the rugby world cup must be crazy
yeah i mean
just to share those
moments i talk about throughout a week
um yeah
that's so cool to do with your brothers
um
it's one thing to just be in that
environment and
make new friendships and hang out with
your teammates but
to do that with your brother is yeah
it's so rewarding
and uh often i'm reminded of those
moments on the back lawn we we used to
i used to pretend to be andrew murdens
and um
jordy maybe christian cullen or whatever
and
to be living those that dream um you
often would just think gosh
this is amazing one thing a lot of
questions came in about
was the move to the blues obviously
you're a hurricane's legend um i
remember
this move quite vividly i remember
rooming with you and joberg in south
africa when you first sort of mentioned
it
and told me the situation
i remember how tough it was for you do
you want to talk about
that decision and what it came down to
in the end
yeah it was um
a very difficult one
and one that i mean i'd had
previous offers by the blues um
in fact i was offered him at the same
time i
signed the wider training group contract
in 2011 the blues offered two
full seasons so and then again three
years later
jk and obviously this one so
it's kind of like third time lucky
but it was yeah it was
to leave a club where you've played 120
games uh things like
your father's played for the club your
brother's playing for the club
um a team that you've looked up to and
adored for you know all your life um
watching the greats play
kali tana and so on
but probably more the teammates those
bonds and connections and friendships
you've
uh made and you enjoy and
the reason the big reason you play footy
those that was probably the hardest
thing
like i was becoming a little bit
board of the same same of the same
environment
um same it just got a little bit
repetitive to me and i needed
some sort of change or stimulation if i
wanted to stay in new zealand and play
for the all blacks and not go offshore
for good
and play footy so um
yeah it was also a personal
family decision so we thought
look we're going to end up living in
auckland at some stage wellington isn't
home
you know i'm a knacky boy
my wife and i met
2013 just studying
um so we had a good stint down there
together
and we felt it was time
i wanted to make a shift to auckland
while still playing and make that
transition whilst playing
because i wanted to challenge myself in
a different environment stimulate myself
to ultimately become a better all black
and better player for new zealand
um because once again i don't want to go
overseas at that stage
and it's obviously hannah's home um
it was always going to be our future
home so i was like look let's
that was a big deciding factor um
life quality i love living in auckland
it's a
um it's great having
hannah's family support around uh family
and friends
around and it has so much to offer as
well
so and i'll get my barbecue out
five nights a week instead of once a
year
but uh so there are so many different
factors
um but it came down to
ultimately a quality of life like
am i living the best life i can because
yes rugby is important but
i can still play rugby and have the best
life we can have
as a family in auckland so i thought
i just ticked so many boxes
yes the
legacy of being a one club person
played on my mind was a factor yes
leaving geordie was a big factor
or a big big burden um
and of course leaving teammates cozy
tj and so on you know that was tough
um but yeah ultimately it was a decision
for
me for my family and yeah i'm loving it
up here
well i think anyone with kids i think
anyone with kids will understand how
important it is to have someone around
who can help out with your kids help out
take the kids when you need it give you
some just that extra pair of hands and
you obviously didn't have that in
wellington but you had that in auckland
and like you say um family comes first
and
i think a lot of people i know a lot of
the keynes boys accepted
your decision and it made a lot of sense
to me personally anyway
yeah exactly and um
i'm so happy that we did make the
decision when we did
um i don't know if i would have been
too happy down in uh and and wellington
if i stayed and um
i think it is important to stress that
there is a bigger picture here
uh we play rugby for a very short amount
of time and yeah
it was about me living my best life
while still playing in new zealand
and also thinking of our future
it didn't mean you're not going to play
them again though so straight away you
had a couple of games against them the
following year
yeah the first one was a classic uh you
obviously knew kelsey was coming
yeah and he came he scampered
i forgot how quick he was and heavy
oh what about the celebration though oh
that was such a cool moment like
um yes i wish i tackled him in the
corner
yeah but i was meant to be he scored a
try on me
and you know that celebration was was
pretty funny
i was a little bit rattled i had to
bounce back
and get on with it that's such a cool
attitude that you've got a lot of guys
would just completely fire up there
but you just took that on the chin and
you copped it like a champion and you
kept playing and obviously still led the
blues to victory that day
yeah i had i was rattled especially
because the main man
touching my head was scrafton who was
the blue the previous year so
quite ironic
um but no it was funny i love the bands
with kalsi
oh in the other video of him uh on
playercam
chasing you and pushing you and then you
chase him
honestly he just wanted to really put a
shot on me but he
when i say shot like a good old punch in
the ribs or
or whatever but he didn't really get the
opportunity to so
this is his moment i think it was in the
70th minute it was quite late
yeah because you chase after him i
wanted to like tackle him but i would
have
i would have got penalized for it yeah
so i tried a cheeky foot trip
did he say anything because even on his
podcast he said that there was something
he just never wanted to say anything to
you didn't want to
go overboard yeah no there was never
um any nasty words
it was more just the anger was in his
eyes and
that you know that that point he gives
you when he
bites his grits his teeth yeah
oh he's classic love him and then but
obviously the other game
at the cake tin now this was something
that sort of grinded my gears a little
bit
um the return of the king you came back
in the blues jersey this time the crowd
was booing you
um and to hear that hannah was i guess
uh abused from the crowd and stuff was
thrown at her
it was all pretty disappointing to hear
so how did you feel about all that
um at the time i was gutted like
i never knew it would be easy to come
back and play
the canes play my teammates
but to hear it from fans it was it was
disappointing
um i don't like doing full stop like
i appreciate when we play overseas
and you know it's quiet when kickers are
kicking
um they respect the kicker and so on um
so yeah it was
it was so disappointing to hear that um
i understand they're
gutted and to be fair they probably
don't know how to
support someone or show dislike for
someone
in any other way other than billing so i
took it for what it was afterwards when
i looked back on it but yeah it was
disappointing
when half the game had was quite upset
you know people were throwing stuff at
her that was that's what really annoyed
me
um yeah
very disrespectful so um
[Music]
that wasn't the homecoming i was hoping
for
um but i understand that
fans are passionate uh they obviously
gathered that i was wearing a blue
jersey and to be fair they were probably
just doing the fact that i wasn't a blue
jersey
i think that's right but yeah the part
with hannah is pretty much
unacceptable that's that's shocking but
um that game on the field you you scored
a nice try
sold tj up the river with a nice dummy
but nani got you back pretty good
he did i was yeah
he's um oh you'd know jebet
anyone who can run around you over your
daunting to defend
especially when you give them so much
space
so yeah i was sat on my backside
ran around but he's just
he's a freak of an athlete though so i
wouldn't say i was surprised
i was just unfortunate to be in that
position he's done it to
too many too many players
yeah banksy said on his one that he now
feels happy that
he's been done because you've been done
so if the best part in the world
it's been down there that's all right
everyone else can be
yeah he's um oh i absolutely love
playing with nuns
um it's sad to see him going
but i can i can i understand his
decision it's
um he's thinking in the big picture
he's been patient and
yeah fair play time he'll be missed big
time
yeah well yeah i felt like i thought he
was potentially going to go last time
his contract was up
i felt like he wasn't probably getting
the rewards he probably deserved and
the story i thought maybe he might since
he's sort of cracked in now i thought he
might have stayed this time but
no that's the thing it's like you say
it's only you're only in the game for so
long and
you've got to look after yourself
because there is no loyalty in the game
i mean i guess
the guys at the very top sort of get
looked after up into a point but
um here's so often i completely agree
guys guys just get as soon as their form
drops they are gone so
you can't afford to really be loyal it's
not really a
franchise or province that's loyal or
disloyal it's
usually the head coach or high
performance guy who either likes you or
he doesn't so
yeah you know that's probably one thing
the fans don't see
yeah it's um
yeah there's a lot more to it than just
the franchise and staying for that
for that reason i've been a one club
person or whatever you'll be a hurricane
for 10 years a new coach comes on he
doesn't like you
and now you're good yeah that's it
you're spot on
but anyway mate you're back in new
zealand now um
you're available for the all blacks in
this next squad yep
yep we are um brody
tj myself are all available 10 or 15.
i prefer 10 you've always known
us
yeah look i've really enjoyed my time
playing for suntory
wearing the ten jersey there and that
reminded me how much
i enjoy that influence and
[Music]
more of a set piece um phase decision
maker
there just a little bit closer to the
the engine room and
can have a bit more say so yeah i think
um for me i'll be i'll be focusing on
that
and your kicking game seems to be on an
absolute zone you
you kick variation you're kicking the
fat nicely
you've got all sorts of good kicks going
on kicking the fat is
yeah i've i've been working with dave
orrid uh
for for uh
16 months now and
unfortunately i've only had the
opportunity to work with him physically
for one day
the rest has been just video and uh
whatsapp so
you know i'd love for him to come over
to new zealand and
teach cooking here because his knowledge
around
all round kicking game is just
exceptional the best of um
i've worked with so he's helped me with
my spiral
um basically every all parts of kicking
and you're hitting your goal kicks
nicely now too aren't you
yeah i've been chipping away with um
small changes um but what i like about
dave is
uh he treats the drop kick and the
goal kick pretty much the same so it's
from a practicing point of view there's
some real good continuity and
um lessons to be learned there
but also around the way he structures
his training sessions like that's
that's probably the biggest biggest
shift i've made around the way i
practice yeah and it that should help me
um for my longevity in the game as well
so what it what do you do differently is
it just shorter
so instead of going out there and
hoofing balls
as hard as i can like winding it right
back and
kicking at a less intensity
physically so picking at say 40
intensity but obviously 100 attitude and
mindset and focus it's very challenging
but
it's yeah so rewarding and
it teaches you how to do the
fundamentals yeah
better and properly and talk to me about
your goal kicking throughout your career
obviously it's something that
i guess you've copped a little bit of
flack for throughout your career
unnecessarily in my opinion i thought
you've obviously kept pretty
consistently you've kicked for a long
time
um have you felt the pressure from fans
and media around
your goal kicking yeah look it's
um it's never been
my point of difference or strength
um so to speak but
yeah there have been seasons where i've
had two or three bad days at the office
and that's typically given me uh
uh not so good press or
uh perception on on how i kick the ball
but um
it's something i really enjoy and
i'll always enjoy it i always enjoy
working and practicing on it
um kickers will keep kicking mate
there'll always be those those haters
and those
people criticizing but you know i'm
always striving to
to be better and look what dave's
doing with me at the moment i'm really
enjoying that and he's um
he's already made some good games with
me so hopefully
you'll see that and uh to be honest
i don't really listen to that the media
it's always going to be there but
uh it doesn't bother me well matt you're
striking them nicely in the top leg so
looking forward to that crossing over
to the black jersey and the blue so
you're with the blues next season
yep back with the blues next season so
yeah looking forward to having a full
season
full two seasons with them actually
because you signed with them for four
years right
yep one half season
uh then the suntory season was nice
playing sabbatical
and then i've got two full years with
them so yeah
really looking forward to that to
clarify for everyone listening you that
was always
part of the contract wasn't it some
people have suggested that you
sign with the blues and then you've sort
of surprised the sabbatical on them
but i've always so from day when i
signed it was a four-year deal and that
was
black and white built in i think people
just
forget when making an announcement it's
like blues they see the blues but they
don't see all the
yeah you know years two three four yeah
so what what are your plans going
forward you obviously got the blues
um to look forward to you got the rugby
world cup potentially to look forward to
yes uh blues next year
um i mean love i'll get it on thursday
you can't play straight away can you
well if there's an injury
oh you can yeah
um so i'll go and do some training with
them
uh hopefully the week of the final and
uh catch up with the boys and then
you hope they can win the trans tasman
so you could plan the blues hurricanes
final
coming up technically it's well it is
possible wow
you at tntj at night
like it would take uh for a couple of
blokes
otsi and i don't want to even mention it
like couple of injuries yeah shame would
be a shame for other
you did did he ever come into your mind
when you decided to sign with the blues
are you dead yeah yeah
but uh like that year i went um
my first season i was playing it mostly
at fullback so
yeah um i was happy
to offer what i could at the back um
and otzi continued playing i think it
was the best team that we
could have had at that time i agree you
guys had a good combination too
yeah i couldn't have done it to him yeah
he's a good kid yep yeah he's a good
player
so life after rugby four big bowdoin
barrett what's the plans you can
probably retire
living off with the coin you've made i
hope so um because i've been
investing well and thinking of
the future i've always been um a little
bit
savvy when it comes to to that business
and that
so i want to be
financially free but i know that i
will i won't better retire and do
nothing
um but i don't know what what it is
i'll be doing initially it might be
being a stay home dad and
freeing up pam to go and do whatever she
would like to
carry on doing with her career yeah not
that she stopped she's still finding
um well she's still got heaps of work on
she's on a board of a company and um
also doing
a lot of her social media things so
she's an accountant um chartered
accountant naturally but
who knows where she could go next mate
you're a power couple you too aren't you
but you would be a guru stay home dad
how have you found being a dad
i've loved it absolutely love it
um yeah i could i could
i could do it i'd be happy to do it
and um yeah i'll support
my wife if she wants to go to a
full-time job
i'm sure there'll be a good day here
down the road where i could drop the
kids off and go and play golf most days
what a dad have you got any plans for
any more kids
yeah we'd like to we'd like to push on
so billy's only 11 months now
11 months eight months and um
yeah we'd like to kick on um
i don't know how many three or four
would be nice not like your parents
we don't we're not spoiled for space
or a farm up in up in auckland so um
you're having eight kids in in town to
be quite
yeah crazy eight kids in general it's
madness don't know how your parents said
it
yeah how's billy going is she what's her
personality like
she is full-on she is
um yeah she's full on
i think she has a lot of her mother's
personality
and um yeah she can be quite
very joyful very fun um can be quite
demanding and needy
yeah so yeah she's she's awesome she's a
little ripper
oh that's good stuff anyway what a
journey what a career as always we've
gone to our instagram
for some questions and i say this a lot
but
oh you've literally got thousands here
so i'm just going to be able to choose a
few
but there's some good ones in here first
question how do you practice your mental
skills
i've got a couple of routines i do
each week which
which channels my thoughts and
i guess allows me to be focused on
what i need to focus on come kick off
and game time
it's easy to become really cluttered uh
you know with so much happening in life
with social media
um you know general media
uh people's opinions and so on so
naturally they'll come and creep in so i
do a little thing called
three circles can control can't control
can influence and
literally i just put all my thoughts and
those circles
um i do that towards the end of a week
and that allows me to feel really light
bright and clear come the back end of
the week
and then allows me to just
i guess play freely and instinctively
and
puts all those things aside
geez i like that you can do it even if
you're not playing footy just in general
yeah yeah very cool great start
okay how do you deal with people hyping
up players in your position
um
oh look at hype is is something that
is just getting bigger and bigger with
social media these days there are so
many different channels and
um you know there's so much more these
days that
uh there's a lot more hyping up but
there's also a lot more criticizing it's
just the way it is everything's a bit
more extreme
so um naturally it's like oh that's
naturally it doesn't sit well with you
you're a little bit uncomfortable you're
like gosh i wish that was me but
um you know the next week it can be
completely different
so that's just the way it is with
media and uh with this game we play a
lot can happen in seven days
sure can you're 100 right you can be
absolute hero to villain in
the space of a week or two games can't
ya
this brings on to the next sort of
question heaps of questions are about
this guy
richie milwanga what are your thoughts
on richie milanga
oh he's an absolute top bloke um
i can i don't have a bad thing to say
about him so
um yeah he's a great family man
he's uh he's an entertaining lead great
guy to be around
um but i just love being in the same
team as him
when it comes to the all blacks um
i've enjoyed a little 10 15
um combination
because yeah we believe that it was uh a
good thing for the team and
um yeah
he's playing out of a skin at the moment
he's yeah
yeah he's on another level so um
yeah i look forward to getting back into
hopefully the the all black environment
and um you know going at it again with
them but we keep in touch
often um we've got a really good
relationship
and it kind of makes me laugh when you
see all these other things on social
media it's like
yeah apparently they knew how good we
get on and
it's always been the case with our
greatest
you know competitors or teammates
do you think it says yeah to play
fifteen
says yeah yeah i see when
i think he might have finished up back
there last week so i'll be quite happy
if that's the
it's his turn is that what you're saying
yeah i'll turn it yes
but to be fair there's that many good
fallbacks around two at the moment
there sure is that's great it's
so good for the all black squad
um you know i think it's
also needed i see it is essentially
15 test matches so yeah uh
you know we're gonna need to use
the full squad um the whole depth and
it's gonna be tough to decide who who
starts there
you know in the first few games but it's
a good problem to have
yeah we're plumb on last week and he was
struggling to decide but if you were the
selector who would you go
10 15 you can pick yourself no i can't
i'd go marty banks
and jordy
you see banksy up in up in japan
yeah he's doing things that you've never
seen before
tackling tackling
oh we got a question from banksy
uh is bodes well a champion
yep bodes well as a champion
bodes there must be one of your um
investments that you're talking about
your savvy investments
gosh my other investments are a bit
safer than this one
but yep jabber you know bodes well
very well he's one of our well he's our
um horses
uh and the nike had the opportunity to
go to australia
and um as a stayer i believe so
it was ill not long ago um
put him back in the paddock to rest up
and and get ready for a big spring is
that the plan jabba
yeah i think that's a plan and he shows
a lot of qualities like his old man you
he can he can go forever he's just he's
just probably short of that six-week
speed program to be fair he's just sort
of left that top-end speed so
i think he's gone back to the paddock
for that six-week
speed uh program because he's
he finishes strong doesn't he he does
i'm actually looking forward to getting
on track with
you and banksy at one race meeting and
winding him home hopefully
absolutely okay
next question what's your best wow am i
actually here moment
well i'm actually here
gosh it's been a lot
it's been a lot like
super bowl was one oh that's right
yeah super bowl uh in miami
last year was definitely one
actually that first
sevens uh tournament i was in
yeah we played in um
i was in twickenham at twickenham and
we arrived a bit earlier to prepare for
a game and we were watching other sevens
teams and
i just sat there in the seats in the
stand i was just thinking wow
like is this like i'm actually here
i was at school last year now i'm at
twickenham about to plan a
sevens competition for new zealand like
that was pretty
awesome yeah that's a good one okay
how many times do you say seed in a game
this is from oh teddy black
oh when i watch him i sat all the time
whether it's a pass or a kick
yeah it's every time i see
yeah geordi had a good one or otzie had
a good one
the other ones i used that phrase with
the most yeah they kick some seeds
okay keys to a good bronco well you've
got to be fat
you've got to know your plan and
my plan is do the first
lap about 80
um and then after that i try and stay
with whoever's leading
for um
basically for three three laps
yeah and then after that i've still got
a bit in the tank and i just
just send it after you know for my last
lap
just to try and that that
that has broken tj many times
he knows that if so he goes he goes out
real hard to try and lose me because
he knows i don't want to blow out too
soon but i just
fight and stay with them for as long as
i can i know that if i've got them on
the last then
yeah i just yeah
so that's it what happens if you're
running it by yourself
well you can time it so you just
stick to your um split
45 seconds or whatever they are um
yeah that's how some people do it that's
probably the best way to train for it
but tj does he cleans me up on the yo-yo
so it's good to get him in the bronco
does he i don't think yeah anyone in a
yo-yo
no he's pretty good he's good at those
turns
yeah oh he loves that okay
if you could next question if you could
get on the piss with three
people dead or alive who would it be oh
geez
i've been spending some time with sean
mcmahon up in
japan he is one man he has a weapon
yeah he's an absolute weapon he's got a
tattoo on his
leg in the weekend
and he's also got a vb like he's got all
these tattoos he's a
he's an absolute rooster but because
i've been doing
i've had a few sessions with him i won't
say him uh
john daly i'd love to play golf
rip it grip it and sip it with him um
john daly honestly i've been away from
the nike for that long i'd throw white
bait on the list
right now oh rooster craig hammersley
um and
oh my rooster mates i've just got to say
the roosters
the roosters love it that's a good
answer
okay your favorite wine oh
uh that is very difficult
um
i buy a lot of my wine through off euro
vintage
and my go-to red wine in new zealand is
any tamata from the hawke's bay
they're coloring or bullnose
syrah right up there
kind of sir i like that yeah colorings
are
um that's their premium
premium red but their bullnose is a
yeah top notch
get me on there that sounds so hard
there's so many good new zealand wines
but that would that be my go-to you're
japanese
how's your japanese now uh
i can understand conversation a lot
better than
previously um like i understand a lot of
random words but i can't like put
a sentence together if you know what i
mean are you still saying offensive
words in japanese
most probably you know like that
do you remember your hanzai oh god
yeah that was
took me through that original one of my
favorite pranks hey
i've never forgiven cj for that
oh how did we fall for that
it looked like a pretty legit setup it
was
and yeah you didn't want to be
disrespectful and
as a as a young all black
we never said no we're always like yep
yep
absolutely so um so yeah we were
right for the picking and yeah they
really
stitched us up i wish i'd pay a lot of
money to have that
destroyed off the internet
how much are we talking because i think
it was for cure kids wasn't it so
yeah yeah it was for a good cause oh
absolutely
yeah yeah i always happy doing things
with your kids
but i'm scarred
and every now and then it gets revisited
on
yeah i run for the hills we'll have to
bring it up again
oh it's one of those it makes me laugh
kelsey's is just as colesies is probably
worse girls he's doing all sorts of
stuff
running from the shark and hanzo
oh so good
okay which barrett goes best on a bender
um
geordi's probably the most conditioned
um oh yeah probably julie
hard to argue he goes good
okay the process to releasing your book
now this is a book that i've been
reading
most nights my son toby loves it loves
the bodhi barrett book
what's the process to releasing that
it was really um
it was quite random like we went into
lockdown in 2000 and
last year and
my agency suggested um
ricky swanell as an author
or to write it and basically ricky and i
over
probably 10 zoom calls for an hour or so
managed to get enough content or
basically it was an interview like this
she got enough
content for her to write everything out
then when we got out of quarantine
or out of isolation um we managed to do
some filming
or some capturing images and for the
drills and all that
um as well as mum
mum's kept like a big scrapbook and a
lot of photos and that so we managed to
put this thing together pretty quickly
and it was
basically something for kids where i can
share my story on
my upbringing right through to my first
all black test
so um there's obviously a lot more
a lot of stories that i haven't included
on that um
and hopefully that might be for a later
day but it's more for
kids um
teaching them how i did it it's not to
say it's the way to do it but it's just
my perspective and my
my story wow
not just toby loves it i love reading
that book every night it's one of my
favorite books big fan
what a read my son toby was obsessed
with geordie
obviously jordy was nice to him but then
jordy doesn't have a book and he gets to
read the body book every night so
you're fast becoming the favorite oh
let's just get him on that six-week
program and he'll be sorted
okay last question one piece of advice
you would give to a young kid who's
trying to fulfill their dream
like probably not to let
people's opinions discourage you
and
be patient like
in my journey some of my biggest
doubters were my
some of my coaches like at a young
young age and
thankfully i had some good support
around me like my parents
who would always encourage me that
probably outweighed the influence or
i guess opinions of some coaches
because it can be very political at a
young age
and even right right through to the top
so
if there's a coach that doesn't like you
or won't pick you or start you or
whatever don't
get too disheartened or don't give up
there i mean
just use that as motivation and be
patient to
get another opportunity somewhere else
it could be a year later or it could be
five years later so
effectively just keep loving the game
keep enjoying it and if you do that then
everything will take care of itself
mate that is powerful powerful advice
from the best to ever do it
mate it's been an absolute pleasure to
have you on the podcast
it's been a pleasure to go through your
journey you're one of the most gifted
players i've ever played with i loved my
times playing with you at the hurricanes
i genuinely don't think i would have had
the
career i did at the hurricanes if you
weren't at 10
um you're a massive influence on me i
learned so much from you and it's been
awesome following your journey
um keeping in touch over the years and
uh mate it's been an absolute pleasure
having you on the podcast
um and going through your story thank
you jabba
absolute pleasure mate um look you're
one of my favorite teammates
uh that may be in the book actually that
you read that you read every night
um five years in a row you were
team man of the year what was it three
three three yeah three okay absolute
pleasure mate um
look forward to hearing this and
hopefully the
fans got what they wanted out of it and
um yeah pleasure to be on waterlab
oh mate love your work thanks for coming
on thanks mate
[Music]
what